[موسيقى]
محيطاتنا لا تزال غير مستكشفة إلى حد كبير
وتحتوي على العديد من الألغاز
والتحديات على شواطئ أبوظبي
جئت للقاء فريق يحقق في
الدور الذي يمكن أن تلعبه الروبوتات في
محيطاتنا، نستخدم أنواعًا مختلفة من الروبوتات
تسمى بعض الروبوتات السطحية غير المقيدة
المركبات التي تبقى على سطح
الماء، ثم لدينا الطائرات بدون طيار تحت الماء
التي تُستخدم في
العمليات تحت الماء، يقومون بنشر هذه
الروبوتات لأداء تحديات مختلفة، وهم
اليوم يحاكيون مهمة حيث
يمكن استخدام الروبوتات يومًا ما للتنظيف
محيطاتنا، نعم، لديها
كاميرا خاصة بها، فهي في الأساس تتعرف بشكل
مستقل على البلاستيك، وتذهب إلى هناك
وتلتقط البلاستيك، لذا تلتقطه،
وتلتقطه، وتلتقطه، ثم
لدينا القوارب الأخرى مثل التي تحتوي على
هذه  السلال ويسقطها هناك
وبعد ذلك يمكن لهذا القارب أن يتجه نحو
الفحم الحجري وحيث يمكنك إزالة ذلك
[موسيقى]
البلاستيك يتم إجراء هذا البحث في مجال
الروبوتات البحرية المستقلة بواسطة
فريق في جامعة خليفة في أبو ظبي
ولدينا حوالي 90 باحثًا
يعملون في  جوانب مختلفة من الروبوتات،
تنظيف البلاستيك، فحص الشعاب المرجانية،
تربية الأحياء المائية في سرب الروبوتات في مختبر الروبوتات هذا،
يعلق الطلاب مجموعة من التكنولوجيا
بما في ذلك الكاميرات وأجهزة الاستشعار في هذا
البحث،
تتيح لهم تقنية محاكاة موجة المسبح إجراء دراساتهم
باستخدام برنامج متقدم Ai
والخوارزميات التي يقومون بتحليل البيانات  أنا
أعمل في هذا المجال منذ
الثمانينات ولم يكن هناك وقت مثل
هذا التقدم التكنولوجي الذي يغير
نهج العلماء في التعامل مع الروبوتات،
وصول الذكاء الاصطناعي هو تغيير قواعد اللعبة، إن تحقيق
هدفهم المتمثل في بناء
روبوتات مستقلة تحت الماء ليس بالأمر السهل.
إذا كان لديك نظام تحديد المواقع العالمي (GPS) على سبيل المثال تحت الماء، فإن
رؤيتك ضعيفة لديك أمواج
وتيارات
وتصطدم بك أه، التواصل في كل اتجاه صعب
للغاية بالإضافة إلى
العديد من المشكلات الصعبة، التحدي
هو أنه من خلال الإصرار المطلق
والبحث المستمر يهدف هؤلاء العلماء
إلى
التغلب عليها